IT’S AN INVENTION OF THE LEFT.
>> Laura: THANKS, MATT.
I WANT TO GO TO TO AFTERMATH OF
THE CHAUVIN TRIAL.
AN ALTERNATE SPEAKING OUT ABOUT
THE SENSE OF FEAR THAT SHE AND
HER COLLEAGUES FELT.
HERE’S WHAT LISA CHRISTENSEN
TOLD CNN YESTERDAY.
>> I WAS CONCERNED TO MY SAFETY
TO A POINT THAT WE HADN’T HEARD
ANY FACTS OR ANYTHING YESTERDAY.
SO DEPENDING WHICH WAY IT WENT,
I FELT LIKE SOME PEOPLE -- YOU
CAN’T PLEASE EVERYBODY ALL THE
TIME.
I FELT CERTAIN GROUPS MIGHT FEEL
CERTAIN WAYS.
I WAS CONCERNED ABOUT THAT.
>> Laura: SHE WAS MORE
>> Laura: SHE WAS MOREWITH A
LOCAL REPORTER.
ALAN, IT’S HARD TO IMAGINE THAT
SENSE OF FEAR DIDN’T IMPACT THE
JURY IN SOME WAY.
BUT WE WON’T KNOW, I GUESS.
WE’LL NEVER KNOW.
YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> WE SHOULD NO.
THERE’S NOT A REASON THE JUDGE
SHOULD HAVE CALLED IN EVERY
SINGLE JURY AFTER CONGRESSWOMAN
WATERS MADE HER STATEMENTS.
WHY NOT CALL IN THE JURORS AND
ASK THEM, DO YOU KNOW ABOUT THIS
STATEMENT?
HAVE YOU HEARD ABOUT IT?
ARE YOU AFRAID?
DO YOU HAVE THE KIND OF FEAR
THAT IF YOU COME OUT WITH A
VERDICT THAT WILL NOT PLEASE
SOMEONE IT COULD CAUSE RIOTS?
I HAVE ABSOLUTELY ZERO DOUBT
THAT JURORS IN THAT JURY ROOM
WERE WORRIED ABOUT THEIR WELFARE
IF THEY WERE TO COME TO A
CONCLUSION THAT MURDER WAS NOT
COMMITTED?
IF THEY HAD COME TO A VERDICT OF
MANSLAUGHTER OR NOT GUILTY, THEY
WOULD WORRY THEIR WELFARE, THEIR
CHILDREN, THEIR BUSINESSES,
THEIR SCHOOLS, THEIR
NEIGHBORHOODS WOULD BE BURNED
DOWN.
THEY WEREN’T THE ONLY ONES THAT
WERE WORRIED.
EVERY POLICE CHIEF, THE MAYOR.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES SAID THE JURORS WERE
UNDER ENORMOUS PRESSURE.
THAT’S NOT THE WAY IT’S SUPPOSED
TO OPERATE.
JURORS ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
ISOLATED, INSULATED, SEGREGATED
AND KEPT IN A SEPARATE HOTEL
ROOM DURING THE ENTIRE PROCESS
AND NEVER SHOULD HAVE BEEN
ALLOWED TO HEAR WHAT PEOPLE LIKE
MAXINE WATERS WERE THREATENING.
>> Laura: ALAN, REALLY QUICK
QUESTION.
ARE YOU CONCERNED ABOUT A
PRECEDENT BEING SET WITH THIS
TRIAL WITH FUTURE TRIALS OF
PEOPLE, POLICE OFFICERS, OTHERS
WHOSE OUTCOME -- DOESN’T THIS
SET ITS OWN PRECEDENT?
>> WE ALREADY SEE THAT WITH KIM
POTTER THAT COMMITTED NO CRIME
WHATSOEVER HAVING BEEN CHARGED
WITH MANSLAUGHTER.
WE SEE IT WITH THE OTHER THREE
ACCESSORIES.
WE DON’T KNOW WHETHER THEY WILL
GET A SEQUESTERED JURY.
THE TRIAL WILL TAKE PLACE IN
MINNEAPOLIS.
THAT IS A MISTAKE.
IT’S GOING TO BE VERY HARD FOR
THE JUDGE IN THAT CASE TO MAKE A
DECISION WHETHER TO SEQUESTER.
IF THE JUDGE SEQUESTERS, IT WILL
BE A SLAP IN THE FACE.
IF THE JUDGE DOESN’T SEQUESTER,
HE OUGHT TO LEARN HIS LESSON.
>> Laura: THE CONSTITUTION I
DON’T THINK WE WANT TERRIFIED
JURORS.
OKAY?
TERRIFIED JURORS ARE GOING TO BE
UNDER ENORMOUS PRESSURE TO COME
DOWN ONE WAY OR THE OTHER AND